[Musica]
volevo fare la cantante
e invece sono qui a provare alla
contabili come ho fatto a diventare una
fotografa anzi di come è successo
credo che tutto sia iniziato con i miei
disturbi alimentari
io mi sono ammalata all'età di 14 15
anni non lo ricordo ancora con
precisione ma ci sono davvero tante
tanti pezzi di quel periodo che che
ricordo ancora in maniera molto confusa
e un adolescente e come ogni adolescente
mi guardavo e non mi piacevo ma non era
soltanto non piacermi a livello fisico
era qualcosa di diverso era come se
all'improvviso io non mi riconoscessi
dall'immagine che vedevo di me credo che
l'adolescenza
da un lato si al momento in cui iniziamo
a vederci un po come una prima versione
di essere umano definitivo è quello che
vedevo non mi corrispondeva credo però
che proprio questa non corrispondenza
questa sorta di scollamento che c'era
tra me e l'immagine che vedevo di me
abbia avuto una parte fondamentale nel
farmi poi avvicinare alle attivisiti la
fotografia è arrivata qualche anno dopo
sugli scaffali della biblioteca comunale
di reggio emilia la città in cui sono
nata e la prima persona che ho iniziato
a fotografare sono stata io e
fondamentalmente poi vi dirò sommando
non ha praticamente mai smesso fast
forward mi iscrivo al dans mi laureo
frequenta una scuola di fotografia mi
diplomo non proprio in quest'ordine e
decidono certo punto di essere pronta
per provare a fare il mio primo vero
progetto fotografico e quindi deciso di
lavorare su qualcosa che conoscevo molto
bene i disturbi alimentari
io
da adolescente volevo dimagrire però
prendete questa questo termine dimagrire
come una metafora
in realtà volevo diventare la persona
che sentivo di dover diventare e fin qua
solo che volevo diventarlo
immediatamente il tempo che doveva
passare tra quella me così imperfetta
che ero allora e quella media fetta che
naturalmente sarebbe stata nel futuro
era un tempo che doveva passare il più
velocemente possibile
era un tempo inutile un tempo
angosciante tempo vuoto
al contrario del tempo della fotografia
la fotografia per me riempie il tempo
quando si ha una macchina fotografica al
collo ogni momento è potenzialmente un
momento denso di significato importante
ed irripetibile
forte di questa di questo strumento
materiale proprio la macchina
fotografica ma anche mentale insomma
sono partita per piatto di e dal 2006
residenza palazzo francisci che è uno
dei principali centri in italia per la
terapia dei disturbi dell'alimentazione
e ancora mi ricordo che viene
organizzata questa riunione plenaria con
tutti gli operatori e le dottoresse le
pazienti mi ricordo queste venti paia di
occhi che mi guardavano terrorizzati
perché era un estraneo e per di più le
strane con una macchina fotografica
d'altra parte io ero terrorizzata quanto
loro infatti dopo aver parlato insomma
presentate eccetera per una settimana
dieci giorni non ebbe il coraggio di
fare nemmeno una foto
in compenso passare il tempo con le
ragazze guardavo la televisione giocava
a carte
ho imparato a fare delle orrende shop è
fatta maglia ma finché un giorno arrivò
a questa ragazza mi disse paganesimo
queste foto quando inizi a farle
e quindi cominciai questo progetto che
al titolo di of days i giorni dispari da
un brano di ludovico einaudi che
ascoltavo all'epoca ossessivamente e
all'epoca non sapevo neanche la
fotografia né che questo lavoro sarebbe
durato più di tre anni ne che la
fotografia sarebbe diventata la mia
professione e nemmeno che in sostanza
questo lavoro sarebbe stato più di un
semplice mestiere ma sarebbe stato anche
per me è una forma di comprensione di me
stessa e di terapia a volte lo chiamo
non so se anche a voi capita ma mi è
capitato che ci siamo ci sono stati
degli incontri nella mia vita lavorativa
e non sono comunque diciamo lavorativa
che hanno segnato dei punti importanti
del mio percorso uno di questi incontri
è stato quello con simona simona lo
incontrate nel 2008 a palazzo francisci
dov'era stata ricoverata e roma estate
toa vedo al centro appieno piano piano
di pazienti e simona all'inizio mi colpì
per la sua fisicità era alta e ancora
alta molto bella questi capelli neri
folti questi occhi enormi e magrissima
magra magra da morire ricordo stava
sempre seduta in disparte e anche le
altre pazienti è come se faticasse road
avvicinarsi a lei c'era qualcosa in
questo alone di estrema sofferenza che
si portava addosso che attirava e
respingeva le attenzioni parlarle allo
stesso tempo io stessa ci misi svariati
giorni prima di decidermi ad avvicinarla
ea chiederle se volesse farsi fare una
fotografia e lei mi rispose con quella
fermezza quella dolcezza che negli anni
poi ho imparato a conoscere mi disse sì
ma non oggi domani e vorrei che ti
immaginarsi qualcosa di bello
ok passa il resto della giornata a
cercare di pensare cosa potessi fare di
bello in quella situazione
la mattina dopo mi svegliai mi ferma e
da un fioraio e comprai dei gigli perché
in una sorta di forma di augurio
mi auguravo che dalle sue braccia lunghe
nodosa un certo punto potessero
sbocciare dei fiori e questo è stato
l'inizio di un'amicizia che a breve sarà
al suo decimo anniversario
nel frattempo non ho smesso di
fotografare me stessa era come se questo
guardare fuori da me mi costringesse
violentemente in qualche modo a guardare
di nuovo dentro di me tante cose che
credevo di sapere di me ho dovuto
rivederle e cambiarla e proprio grazie a
questo lavoro
dopo questi tre quattro anni di lavoro
sui disturbi alimentari sentivo che la
spinta che mi aveva portato a lavorare
su questo tema andava esaurendosi ed
entra in una fase di di tremenda
confusione nel frattempo la fotografia
era diventata il mio lavoro la mia
professione mi chiesero se se volesse
andare nella striscia di gaza è così
preso dall'entusiasmo e dalla confusione
dice di sì senza pensarci e nell'arco
letteralmente di pochissimi giorni mi
ritrovai in una zona di guerra
ero di nuovo terrorizzata non sapevo che
cosa aspettarmi
forse non è abbastanza preparata ad
andarci per hop attivo da un pensiero io
sono stata la prima donna della mia
famiglia a non avere vissuto la guerra
mia nonna le mie nonne hanno vissuto la
prima e la seconda guerra mondiale
mia madre è nata sul finire della
seconda guerra mondiale io ne avevo solo
sentito parlare
eppure da un po come se questa questa
storia non scorresse anche nel dna della
mia famiglia e nel mio stesso
così decisi di lavorare non sulla prima
linea quindi non di documentare la prima
linea ma di stare a casa stare a casa
con le donne e vedere quale normalità se
ci fosse una normalità ma quale
normalità si poteva aspirare in una
situazione di un conflitto così efferato
e così di lungo termine come il
conflitto israeliano palestinese
pensavo se cercava una familiarità se
cercava una corrispondenza con la mia
vita e con la mia esperienza
avrei potuto trovarlo ovunque impastava
cercarla e così ad esempio con obi wan
ha perso tutto durante l'operazione
piombo fuso operazione militare
israeliana del 2009 aveva perso la casa
aveva perso un figlio e brien di 9 anni
rimasto ucciso e ha un anno di distanza
la prima volta che la incontrai ancora
viveva con gli altri cinque figli e il
marito in una tenda nel luogo in cui
sorgeva la sera sotto la sua casa
possiamo pensavo che fosse lì sono una
delle donne più distanti come background
culturale come scelte di vita religione
parliamo di parlavamo lingue diverse
figli tutto quello che vi potete
immaginare no
e invece cuba fa io mi trovo benissimo
andai a trovarlo a molte molte volte nel
corso di questi di questi anni come
trovava a casa l'ammiravo era una
persona è una persona estremamente forte
se c'è una cosa che ho imparato da
questi viaggi da questo viaggio è stato
un po ad abbandonare una serie di
stereotipi che avevo sugli altri
sull'altra ma anche su di me il più
delle volte mi è successo che dove
pensava di trovare delle differenze
insormontabili
in realtà io abbia trovato delle grandi
somiglianze fast forward 2015 stessa
cosa in kenya a un certo punto incontro
natasha natasha una ragazzina keniota di
13 anni all'epoca
che cosa potevo mai avere io in comune
con questa ragazzina
l'ho incontrata in una scuola a il bis
il a poche ore di macchina da nairobi
dove era stata si era rifugiata dopo
essere scappata dalla mutilazione
genitale dalla sua famiglia che voleva
praticarle la mutilazione genitale per
poi come spesso accade in questi paesi
farla sposare solitamente ad un uomo ma
anche molto più vecchio di lei e
natascia quindi era scappata era finita
vivere per le strade i nairobi e poi era
stata presa da una famiglia che l'aveva
presa servizio ma in realtà era più una
schiava che che è una vera e propria
collaboratrice domestica veniva
maltrattata molestate eccetera fino
anche appunto non venne non venne
salvata e portate all'interno di questa
scuola che ha una sezione apposta per le
ragazzine che scappano di casa e la
thatcher ha molto interessato a me aveva
imparato un po in inglese per strada e
quindi aveva deciso di prendersi il
compito di essere la mia guida
all'interno della scuola e mi seguiva
dappertutto mi mostrava tutto e voleva
sapere tutto quello che io facessi come
come raffa essere una fotografa come la
viaggiare e così via quindi una volta
tornata in italia ha deciso di pagare la
retta scolastica
insomma si può dire che io mi porti il
lavoro a casa ma è una fortuna è un
privilegio enorme quando avevo 18 anni
volevo fare la cantante così mi iscrissi
ad un corso con sainkho namtchylak che è
una cantante siberiana della repubblica
di tuva veramente ti amo moltissimo e al
secondo terzo giovani seminario andai da
lei levissima
o la stoffa per diventare una cantante
posso posso farcela io vent'anni guardò
e mi disse qualcosa che suona un po come
a voi occidentali sempre a pensare
soltanto al risultato e maria il
percorso e ci rimasi malissimo
chiaramente infatti ancora oggi mi
ricordo perfettamente di quella giornata
non so se avevo capito esattamente cosa
mi volesse dire ma mai me lo sono
dimenticato forse pian piano ho iniziato
a capirlo proprio grazie al mio lavoro
il mio lavoro mi costringe a guardare
mi costringe a guardare gli altri mi
costringe a guardare non mi permette di
rimanere come vi dicevo dentro gli
stereotipi che avevo che o volente o
nolente sull'altro e su di me e forse
forse tutte queste donne che ho
conosciuto wafa natascha simona e
moltissime altre sono dei pezzi di
quella me che da adolescente volevo
diventare e forse la storia del mio
lavoro è un piccolissimo pezzo anche
della storia della mia lenta lentissima
guarigione grazie
[Applauso]